Peter Parker spider-man is one of the
most incorruptible characters in the
Marvel Universe he was raised to live up
to an ideal that no one could possibly
ever really live up to and on top of it
he stacks the odds against himself by
adding more and more provisions you
think it all stops at with great power
there must also come great
responsibility but in fact he also adds
another stipulation and that is a
staunch no killing policy much like
Batman spider-man understands the
gravity of taking a life and he swears
to never cross that line but he is humid
and once in a while we do falter
especially in the line of duty how many
times is Peter Parker faltered let's
find out the first instance in which
Peter Parker is directly responsible for
the death of another person is Uncle Ben
while only depicted in flashbacks and
off panel it's due to the in actions of
Peter Parker who had great power but
refused to accept the great
responsibility bestowed upon him that
Uncle Ben met his death but this is old
news and without the dead we don't get
spider-man's so there can't be that much
bad attached to it and the fact is
spider-man himself believes that he's
responsible but it doesn't necessarily
mean that everyone agrees with him so
it's kind of conjecture at this point
the first real time in which Spiderman
actually is responsible for the death of
another person is in 1968 an amazing
spider-man annual number 5 in this story
spider-man is trying to unravel the
mystery of his parents death and in fact
there's strong evidence to suggest that
they were traitorous spies in a mystery
that includes the Red Skull spider-man
actually once of getting attacked by a
character known as the finisher the
finish uses advanced weapons technology
including smart missiles to fire at
spider-man and spider-man ends up luring
one of those smart
into the car the finisher is using it's
hard to argue that spider-man is not
directly responsible for the finishers
death the one could argue with the
finisher didn't want to get blown up by
missiles maybe should have been firing
them in the first place a far more
tragic example of spider-man being
directly responsible for the death of
another is an amazing spider-man number
121 in 1973 now you've heard this one a
million times Norman Osborn the Green
Goblin kidnaps Gwen Stacy Peter Parker's
girlfriend takes her on top of the
Brooklyn Bridge or was it the George
Washington Bridge
she is stunned or unconscious it's
really unclear as to what her state is
Green Goblin bashes into her using his
goblin glider and she plummets to her
doom until spider-man fires a web Line
which catches her suddenly and snaps her
neck Goblin takes credit for her death
saying the fall killed her and not the
web Line but different studies and other
comic books have contradicted this
theory and it's widely held that in fact
spider-man's web line did kill her
although Peter Parker does kind of blame
Norman Osborn for the most part in
Marvel team-up number 12 in 1973
spider-man teams up with the werewolf
and they battle a villainous magician
known as moon dark in the climactic
battle spider-man knocks moon dark into
a portal which deposits him high atop
the Golden Gate Bridge from their Moon
dark falls into the water and dies
spider-man makes a vastly inappropriate
joke at his expense and has never
referred to again in Marvel team-up
number 31 in 1975 spider-man and Iron
Fist team up to battle drom the
backwards man the duo defeated drawn by
smashing a source of power which caused
him to age backwards into nothingness
unlike the last team of spider-man
expresses some characteristic guilt over
his fallen enemy in spider-man vs
Wolverine in 1987 spider-man punches an
innocent woman in the face and kills her
not an illusion not a villain a female
ally in an attempt to avoid inevitable
torture and killing by the KGB Charlie
asks Wolverine to kill her in a cemetery
spider-man shows up to stop it and
another battle between Wolverine and
Spiderman ensues in the commotion
spider-man feels a hand on his shoulder
which he believes is Wolverine and pours
all of his strength into one punch meant
for Wolverine
Charlie was trying to commit suicide and
knowing spider-man was not going to let
that happen she took matters into her
own hands
but this death would haunt Peter Parker
for quite some time in web of Spiderman
91 in 1992 spider-man is battling the
forces of the foreigner and in a
firefight spider-man takes the
previously alive body of one of the
agents and puts it in front of himself
to block the laser blast of another
enemy this kills the agent and the agent
who killed that agent kills himself
so really it's more like a twofer
spider-man has a spider sense agility
and super strength there is
no way he shouldn't have avoided that
blast and instead just used the body of
an enemy for me this is one of the more
egregious offenses an amazing spider-man
483 from 2002 spider-man is battling on
the astral plane with dr. strange he
faces an enemy named shade and throws
shade into his energy storages killing
him shade had been a regular person who
was corrupted by magic spider-man saves
hostages that were kept there by shade
but he still killed him
the only explanation I have for this is
that it's written by J michael
Straczynski who to be fair didn't read a
lot of old Spiderman books an amazing
spider-man 491 while at an airport
spider-man Captain America team up to
defend dr. doom from heavily armed
terrorists one of them fires a missile
which spider-man catches with his web
Line and redirects it out of a hole in
the ceiling right into two additional
terrorists who to be fair I don't think
Spiderman knew those guys were there but
is that really okay friendly
neighborhood spider-man number 3 in 2006
spider-man turns into the other which is
a spider version of himself and then
eats the face of moorland killing him to
be fair though he did just transform
into a spider monster and even more to
the point his wife was being attacked by
an energy vampire who turned out to be a
clone anyway so who cares responsible
for 9 human deaths one suicide and an
accidental burglary turn homicide it's
hardly a body count that rivals the
Punisher or anything but considering the
number of times spider-man has denounced
other characters for extreme tactics
maybe it's a little late to be calling
the kettle black that's all for now
everybody you see you guys next time on
comics explain don't forget to visit us
I'm comic blob net see you later